في احدث التطورات المتعلقه بالوضع في
السودان افاد مراسل الجزيره باستمرار
الهدوء على جبهات القتال بين قوات الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في اليوم
الثاني لسريان اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
الموقع بينهما في جده السبت الماضي واضاف
مراسل الجزيره انه صنع في الصباح الباكر
من اليوم تحليق للطائرات في سماء العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وفي تصريح للجزيره تهم
الفريق ياسر العطا عضو مجلس السياده
بالسودان قوات الدعم السريع بخرق الهدنه
لهجومها على مقر مطابع العمله بالخرطوم
ونهب مخزون الدوله من النقد الوطني
واحتياط بنك السودان من الذهب باسم
الديمقراطيه حسب التعبير ذاته قال مركز
قياده الجيش انه دعا الى الالتزام بالهدنه
وعدم الدخول في اشتباك مع التمرد
من شرق الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسلنا اسامه
سيد احمد اهلا بك اسامه كيف يمر هذا اليوم
الثاني من هذا الاتفاق
نعم ما في هذه اللحظات هناك هدوء حذر في
منطقه جنوب وجنوب الخرطوم
عدا بعض
الاصوات اصوات بعض الاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله ايضا هذه الاصوات لم تكن يعني
مستمره وايضا هذه الاصوات متفرقه هنا
وهناك في هذه المنطقه ولكن في اليوم
الثاني لوقفه لوقف اطلاق النار
شهدت بعض المناطق المتفرقه في الخرطوم ام
درمان جنوب ام درمان كان هناك تحليق
للطائرات
الطائره الحربيه في بعض المناطق جنوب ام
درمان وكذلك سمع سمعت اصوات للاسلحه
الخفيفه والثقيله كذلك هذه
الحرب ايضا امتدت في بعض المناطق
شهدت بعض المناطق في وسط الخرطوم اشتباكات
متفرقه في بعض في منطقه وسط الخرطوم كذلك
في شارع الغابه وكذلك في منطقه في حي
الرميله وسط الخرطوم كذلك شاهد اشتباكات
عنيفه خلال ساعات النهار امس تسببت في
مقتل احد المدنيين والجرحى مواطنين اخرين
واضطر بعض سكان
الاحياء التي كانت متاخمه لهذه المواجهات
محاوله الخروج من منازلهم والاحتماء ببعض
الاماكن التي تبدو اكثر امنا طبعا هناك
ايضا
تحليق للطائرات لطيران الحربي خلال
الساعات الصباح هذا اليوم وبعض الكثير من
المناطق خاصه في منطقه شرق النيل شهدت
هدوءا حذرا منذ امس
ذلك اليوم وهذه في منطقه شرق الليل كانت
هذه
مسرحا لتحليق لمستمر لطائرات الحربيه
تابعه للجيش السوداني وكانت تقصف اهدافا
لبعض مناطق التمركز القوات الدعم السريع
كان هذا قبل الاتفاق الهدنه هدنه السابعه
ايام ولكن خلال اليومين اليوم او وايضا
امس لم تكن هناك اي شكل من اشكال القصف او
التحليق بالطيران ولكن تستمر طبعا استمرت
هذه
المواجهات بالامس كان هناك في مدينه
الابيض في عاصمه ولايه شمال كردفان كانت
هناك مناوشات بالاسلحه الثقيله ما بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه استمرت هذه
المناوشات لمده ساعتين لم يكن هناك اي
خسائر بشريه تذكر بحسب مصادرنا التي اتحدث
الذي تحدث الينا من مدينه الاوبيض لكن
كانت هذه
الاشتباكات المواجهات او او المناوشات
كانت قد تسببت خوفا ودعرا للذين يسكنون او
يقطنون في محاذاه هذه هذه المناوشات طبعا
هذه الحرب التي استمرت لخمسه اسابيع
خلفت وضعا انسانيا بالغ التعقيد بالنسبه
لكل المناطق التي شهدت قتالا في خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه ومنذ بدايه الحرب
ولكن هذه المواجهات يرجو الناس هنا ان
تكون هذه الهدنه هدنه سبعه ايام تستمر
وتتطور الى وقف شامل لاطلاق النار خاصه
وان هناك تلويح بالعقوبات من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي واحده من
اطراف الوساطه كذلك للجان
بين فيما يتعلق باختراق الهدنه الوساطه
الامريكيه السعوديه في اتفاق جده لوقف
اطلاق النار كانت قد لوحت به هذه العقوبات
لكل من يخترق هذه الهدنه من الجانبين سواء
من الجانب الجيش السوداني
من جانب